اليوم في مصر ازور بعض المواقع في مصر اجد
المسؤولين من اكبرهم يبكون عايز يلعب في
مصر ويضيعها لازم يخلص مني انا الاول
العلاقه السعوديه المصريه العلاقه صلبه
قويه ما ننساش وقفه اشقائنا معنا ام
الدنيا وابوها الاشقاء الاصدقاء التوتر
يخيم على الاجواء ورائحه النزاعات تفوح
فما الذي يجري بين ام الدنيا وقبله
المسلمين ونقصد السعوديه ومصر وما علاقه
الكيان الاسرائيلي بالامر فقد وقفوا يوما
في خندق واحد وفي صف واحد هناك عاقبت
المملكه امريكا واو بقطع النفط وقتلت مصر
ومعها العرب في جيش واحد واليوم لم يعد
حال الاشقاء يسر الصديق ولكن ها هو يفرح
العدو هل هي سحبه سيف وستمر ام ان للاشقاء
راي اخر فالعرب لا يحتملون شقاقا اخر
فلديهم ما يكفيهم من المشاكل انا موعد
تصفيه النفوسيه هؤلاء عن الاخوه الاعداء
نتحدث وللقصه بقيه توتر الاشقاء فضاء
الاعلام ساحه للسجال خبر بعد اخر ورد بعد
تصريح الم ينتهي زمن التجريح يا اصدقاء
معارك سياديه ازمات اقتصاديه صعبه العربي
يترك اخاه ليواجه مصيره رسائل مبطنه تنتشر
على سماء جزيره العرب هكذا هو حال كبيرتاي
العرب مصر والسعوديه مع تحول القنوات الى
ساحه لتصفيه الحسابات
مستعرا ومتبادل كل يذكر بافضل بلده على
الاخر كل ذلك متزامن مع صمت مطبق لسلطات
الرسميه للبلدين فالى اين ايها الاشقاء
العديد من تطرح والتكهنات تملا المكان فما
الذي يجري بين القاهره والرياض الى فتره
قريبه كان البلدان كالسمن على العسل فذا
يدعم ثمانيه وذاك يرد الجميل سياسيا
والامور ماشيه زي الفل كما يقولها
المصريون لكن هناك من يدوس السم في العسل
هل علمتم من هم
انه
كيان يكتفي بجرائمه في فلسطين بل يخطط ان
لا تقوم قائمه للعرب
فكانت البدايه بعد سنوات من النوم في
العسل للبلدين ومطلع هذا العام 2023
اكاديمي سعودي يدعى تركي الحمد يطلق سبعه
تغريدات تطرق فيها الى الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
في مصر ليربق سياسه الاعلاميه
اما كان عليك ان تتطرق لمواضيع اخرى يا
هذا فهناك مئات المواضيع في بلدك وضعك من
الجاره المصريه
هات
الون صافي الامر بطريقه جريئه ليحصي اسباب
وقوع مصر اسيره لصندوق النقد الدولي قائلا
ان اهم تلك الاسباب هي سيطره الجيش على
دوائر الدوله ومفاصيلها
[موسيقى]
الا ان هناك اشاره سعوديه واضحه نحو مصر
اي الودائع السعوديه لمصر ستكون مشروطه
بعد اليوم فعن اي شروط يتحدثون هنا اتضح
الامر اكثر والسعوديون يرفضون دعوه صندوق
النقد الدولي الاخيره لمساعده مصر ويا له
من رفض ترك الاشقاء في موقف صعب خصوصا مع
تدهور العمله المحليه المصريه في الوقت
الراهن
العلاقه بين الماضي والحاضر خلال العقود
الماضيه مرت العلاقات المصريه السعوديه
بمحطات من المد والجزر ليتوقع الكثيرون ان
تظل تلك المعارك الكلاميه بين الاعلاميين
حبيسه المنصات الرقميه فثم من يصف
العلاقات المصريه السعوديه بالعمود الفقري
للمنطقه العربيه وهنا نطرح سؤالا للعرب من
ذا الذي يرغب في اصابه هذا العمود الفقري
العربي
له مصلحه في ذلك لتظهر هنا احدث التصريحات
العربيه واكثرها جدلا نعم ها هو فنان
العرب السعودي محمد عبده يدخل خطا شائكا
وتغوس قدمه في رمال صحراء الافضل والاعرق
والاكثر ثراء والاكثر تقدما وذلك بقوله ان
السعوديه اليوم لكل العرب هي بيت العرب
مضيفا ان كانت مصر ام الدنيا فالسعوديه
ابوها فهل السعوديه حقا هي ابو العرب
برايكم متابعينا ولنعد الى موضوعنا فيبدو
ان العلاقات بين السعوديه ومصر تشهد
منعطفا جديدا قد تصطدم فيه مصالح الجانبين
ببعضها البعض وسياق الاقتصادي ليس الوحيد
الحاضر في توتر العلاقات بين القاهره
والرياض بحسب ما نقله موقع اوكسيوس
الامريكي فهناك ما هو اعظم من السياسه
والاقتصاد نعم انها الجغرافيا انها التراب
والوطن عام 19
استطاعت مصر استعاده جزيره تيران وصنافير
لتعود الجزيره الى الاحضان المصريه اداره
وحمايه حتى ظهرت السعوديه مطالبه مصر
بتبعيه الجزيره في اكثر من مناسبه لكن لم
يلتفت احد للمطالب السعوديه حتى الثامن من
ابريل 2016 عندما وقعت مع مصر اتفاقيه
تعيين الحدود البحريه بين البلدين وتبقى
لبنود الاتفاقيه فان الجزيره تقعان داخل
الحدود البحريه السعودي
نعم ما سمعتموه وما جرى رسميا وحرفيا
واقره البرلمان المصري عام 2017 وصدق عليه
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي على قرار
نقل ملكيه جزيرتين للسعوديه وهنا تتدخل
اسرائيل بكلمه من هنا وتصريح من هناك ان
مصر متردده بشان تسليم اداره الجزيرتين
لكن هل كل تلك التصريحات الاسرائيليه حبا
في مصر وشعبها ام ان لهم مارب اخرى لن
تبحث تل ابيب الا عن مصلحتها يا اصدقاء
فمصر تمتلك اقوى جيش عربي بل وثاني اقوى
جيش في الشرق الاوسط واحد اقوى الجيوش في
العالم والسعوديه لها ثروات نفطيه هائله
تتحكم باقتصادات العالم صعودا وهبوطا
والاسرائيليون يحلمون بتشتيت الشمل العربي
فهل يتركون مصر والسعوديه لتشكلان عمودا
فقريا لقوه عربيه لا تقهر لكن صفعه عربيه
اصابت اسرائيل في مقتل السعوديه تعيد
المياه لم
جارها العدو الشرس للاسرائيليين مع
المفاوضات المصريه ايرانيه لتصحيح علاقات
البلدين ايضا واسرائيل بين فكي كماشه طرف
عربي
واحبس الصهاينه انفاسه لكن اسرائيل تتنفس
السعداء قليلا برجوعها الى محكمه القضاء
الاداري في مصر التي اصدرت حكمها عام 2016
توقيع اتفاقيه الجزيرتين وايدتها في ذلك
دائره فحص الطعون بالمحكمه الاداريه
العليا بحكمها الصادر في عام 2017 والى
اليوم لم يتم تسليم الجزيره
شروط مصريه ليس هناك شيء رسمي بعد لايضاح
الوضع الحالي لعلاقات القاهره والرياض
فخرجت المعارضه المصريه المتواجده خارج
البلاد مشيره الى خمسه شروط سعوديه لعوده
الامور الى مجارها بين المملكه ومصر ومن
هذه الشروط اقاله جميع الاعلاميين الذين
لا سيما رئيس تحرير صحيفه الجمهوريه
الرسميه اما الشرط الثاني فيشمل تسريع نقل
سياده الى جزيره ايران وسنافير الى
السعوديه ويتمثل الشرط الثالث بوقف دعم
اقامه قاعده روسيه في السودان وتشمل
الشروط منح السعوديه حق
فضلا عن عدم منافساتها في حل الازمه
السودانيه وكان هذه المعارضه سعوديه وليست
مصريه فماذا ترك يا هؤلاء لكن وعلى كل حال
فالعرب عموما ونحن خصوصا مع كل امر من
شانه ان يجمع الشقيقتين مره اخرى للعوده
قبله للدول العربيه واذا كانت السعوديه
ودول الخليج قدموا اكثر من 90 مليار دولار
منذ استيلاء الجيش على السلطه في صيف 2013
بحسب موقع ميدل ايست مونيتور البريطاني
فلماذا يتركون الخليجيون اشقائهم المصريين
اليوم في ازمتهم العسيره حتى ان الموقع
البريطاني اشار الى معلومات تفيد ان
القاهره تفاجات بمطالبه الرياض بسداد
الديون القديمه المستحقه على مصر لشركه
ارامكو السعوديه للنفط والمتعلقه بالشحنات
النفط قبل نحو خمس سنوات كان النظام
السيسي يعتقد ان النفط منحه لا يمكن
سدادها مهلا مهلا ايتها الرياض فالامر لم
يصل لهذه النقطه بعد هل هي حقيقه ام ان
الموقع البريطاني يتصيد في الماء العاكر
في الثاني والعشرين من فبرا
اعلنها وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير
عبد الله هيان للعالم بقوله ان طهران
تتطلع الى استئناف العلاقات مع الرياض
والقاهره مثمنا للدوله العراقيه في تعزيز
الحوار والتعاون بين ايران والسعوديه ومصر
وكذلك دور بغداد في الوساطه بشان الاتفاق
النووي فهل حان الوقت لان يجتمع
العرض ويترك الغرب والاسرائيليين وراء
ظهورهم ما الذي ترونه انتم متابعين
[موسيقى]